(upbeat music)
- Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome.
My name is Gibor Basri.
I'm a professor of the
graduate school in astronomy
and the former Vice Chancellor
of Equity & Inclusion
and a member of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We're very pleased along
with the Graduate Council
to present to you this
afternoon Nina Jablonski,
who is this spring's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
As a condition of the bequest
I am obliged but happy
to give you some of the verbal information
that is also in your
program about the endowment
and how it came to Berkeley.
It's a story that exemplifies
the many ways in which
this campus is linked to
the history of California
and to the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the Army,
came to San Francisco
during the Gold Rush,
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, not long after
this place started,
he established a
professorship here at Berkeley
as an expression of his
long-held interest in education.
His daughter, Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
whose name has probably been seen by you
in reference to a certain
tower in San Francisco,
had a very colorful personality
and was also very generous.
She greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a
professorship at UC Berkeley
and also make it possible for us
to present this series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become
one of the most cherished endowments
for the University of California
and it recognizes the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you Lillie and Charles.
And now a few words about our speaker.
Dr. Nina Jablonski is a
renowned anthropologist
whose current research comprises basic,
clinical, and educational projects.
These include a study of the lifestyle
and genetic factors that
affect vitamin D status
in healthy young adults in South Africa,
the writing of a graphic
novel about skin color
for South African middle-school children,
and the development of a
science summer-camp curriculum
for minority and underserved
middle-school students in the US.
Her research is funded by grants
from the National Science Foundation,
the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation,
and the Rockefeller Foundation.
She is the author of books,
Living Color: The Biological
and Social Meaning
of Skin Color, and
Skin: A Natural History,
both from the University
of California Press.
Dr. Jablonski earned her
doctorate in anthropology
from the University of Washington in 1981,
and her undergrad degree
from Bryn Mawr College
in biology in 1975.
She is the Evan Pugh University
Professor of Anthropology
at the Pennsylvania State University.
She is the director
of the Center for Human
Evolution and Diversity
and the associate director
of the Huck Institutes
of the Life Sciences,
both at Penn State, and a
permanent visiting fellow
at the Stellenbosch
Institute for Advanced Study
in Stellenbosch, South Africa.
Dr. Jablonski has been
recognized most recently
as the recipient of a
2012 Guggenheim Fellowship
for the project Naturalistic
Studies of the Dynamics
of Vitamin D Status in Human Populations,
and the 2005 Alphonse
Fletcher Sr. Fellowship
for the project Improving
the Public Understanding
of the Biological and Social
Meaning of Skin Color.
I think it's safe to say she's an expert
on her subject for this afternoon.
She currently serves as a member
of the Scientific Executive Committee
for the Leakey Foundation,
and a member of the board
for the behavioral,
cognitive, and social sciences
of the National Research Council
of the National Academy of Sciences.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Jablonski.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much for
that generous introduction,
Gibor, and thank you, Ellen,
for your logistical arrangements.
It's a great pleasure to be here
and such an honor to be part
of the Hitchcock Lecture Series.
It's been wonderful to
reconnect with colleagues
that I've known for years
as well as meet some
new young students who hold
the promise of the future for all of us.
Years ago people asked me,
"Why, Nina, are you studying skin?"
Most anthropologists,
most paleoanthropologists
study bones, or fossils,
or the genetics of humans,
but they don't try to understand aspects
of human evolution by looking at skin.
First of all, skin isn't
preserved in the fossil record,
so there are some real shortcomings,
if you're trying to study
the physical remains of skin.
But I realized that by overlooking skin
we overlooked probably one of the most
important parts of the human body.
Our physical interface
with the environment,
our protection, our organ
of thermal regulation,
and our organ of communication
via touch and body decoration.
By missing out on skin we
missed out on a big part
of the study of human evolution.
And so despite the obstacles,
I have enjoyed studying the
evolution of human skin,
and I'm going to share with
you over the next few days
a little bit of that journey.
Today talking about general aspects
of the evolution of human skin,
how we came to have
naked, potentially sweaty,
and extremely colorful skin,
and then tomorrow about
what skin color means to all of us
in terms of our health and
our social relationships
over centuries and millennia.
In 2005 colleagues began to take
a little bit more notice of skin.
In 2005 the genome of the
chimpanzee was published,
and everyone looked at this
paper with great anticipation,
because they expected certainly
when we compare the genomes
of humans and modern chimps
what we would see are enormous differences
in genes dictating the
differentiation of the brain
or the musculoskeletal system.
What was revealed was a
surprise to many, but not to me.
Because the major set of loci
that turned out to be
under most rapid evolution
in the human genome
was that governing the differentiation
of the human epidermis.
In other words it was our skin
that was the most differentiating
part of our genome.
This is because having
mostly naked body skin
is a big departure from
the condition present
in our primate relatives
and our more distant mammalian relatives.
Fur and hair does a lot and without it
we have to compensate in various
ingenious biological ways
that I'll elaborate on
in the next few minutes.
So this really got people
thinking about the evolution
of skin in a much more serious way.
And I must say in the last 12 years
since the chimp genome was published
there has been a greater swell of interest
in the evolution of skin.
One of my favorite visuals is what I call
the hairy timeline of human evolution,
where we have here at the back end
around 7 1/2 million years ago
when we last shared a common ancestor
with our closest relatives, chimpanzees.
And our skin, if we could
look at it back then,
we reconstruct it to be
mostly lightly pigmented
and covered with dark hair,
that of a chimpanzee today.
But through time and critically
just around two million years
ago we see important changes,
and I want to focus on those changes,
because this is when we
really see the transition
to what we would call
ostensibly modern skin:
mostly naked, and sweaty, and colorful.
And it's about this time,
around two million years ago,
and here represented by this impeccable
partial skeleton from Kenya,
we find an early member of the genus Homo,
a beautiful skeleton representing
one of our ancient ancestors.
What's important for you
here is that this individual,
a young man, has very
modern body proportions,
quite different from that of
the Australopithecine ancestors
from previous millions of years,
and the lifestyle of this
hominin is what sets him apart,
and what sets the genus Homo apart,
because it is these long
legs, the broad pelvis,
the relatively short arms that indicate
that this is a person with a modern build.
A strider.
Potentially a runner.
And very different from any kind
of slightly more hesitant biped
or more arboreally competent
biped that existed previously.
We reconstructed the
skin of this individual
to be really mostly naked
and darkly pigmented,
but here what I want to talk
about is why do we reconstruct
this as mostly naked skin at this time?
There are lots of primates
that live in east Africa
and other hot environments
that run around a lot
that have lots of hair.
Why did we lose most of our body hair?
We know from studying human physiology
as well as the physiology
of lots of mammals
that basically having hair
is great protection against abrasion,
great insulation, physical insulation
against cold and temperature fluctuations,
but it physically impedes the process
of the evaporation of sweat.
So even in those mammals
that can produce sweat
on their surface, if
they sweat into the fur,
and the fur gets wet,
their skin cannot actually become cool.
In other words, the purpose of sweating,
which is evaporative cooling, is lost.
What happens if you belong
to a lineage like primates
where most excess body heat
is lost through the skin?
Here are our buddies
that have a lot of hair
that run around a lot,
a beautiful antelope on the right,
a domestic dog on the left.
They liberate excess body
heat in a very different way.
The carnivore on the left
here is able to pant.
The beautiful antelope on the right here
has a wonderful big nose
with lots of veins
and the inspired air that gets brought in
through the wet nasal
mucosa cools the veins
that drain back to the
proximity of the brain
and help to locally cool the brain.
So both of these animals can get quite hot
but they have local cooling
mechanisms in their head
that help their brains to stay cool,
when they're exerting themselves,
especially in a hot environment.
You would think that our primate cousins,
our hairy primate
cousins would do similar,
but even in this long-faced baboon,
we don't have any
structures similar to those
that we find in hoofed mammals
or in the panting respiration of dogs.
Instead even our close relative the baboon
and chimpanzees for that matter
have to lose heat from their body surface
through radiant cooling,
through radiant heat loss and evaporation.
So they lack these specialized
methods of cooling.
When a baboon runs full pelt
for a long distance it
overheats and it stops.
In the evolution of the genus Homo
we find the evolution of a primate
that is walking, and
running, and foraging,
and escaping from predators,
and possibly hunting.
And needing to be able to
sustain energetic locomotion
for a long period of time.
There was natural selection at this time
for the loss of body hair
in order to facilitate
evaporative cooling.
So we hypothesized years ago that the loss
of functional body hair was related
to the needs of thermal regulation.
So here we have this
beautiful young early member
of the genus Homo with mostly
functionally naked skin
and where did the sweat glands come from?
We know that in most mammals
sweat glands of the kind that
we have all over our body
are found only on the surfaces
of the palms and the soles of the feet.
So how did human primates manage to get
all these sweat glands all over the place?
This has been a question
that has pressed people for decades.
We didn't lose all of our hair.
Rather we reduced the
size of the body hair,
so that when you look
at your own body hair
it's this little sort
of measly little things
coming out of hair follicles.
The hair follicles are
enormously important
but where did the sweat glands come from?
And this, as I say, was
an unanswered question
for years until literally
just a few months ago
when my colleague, Elaine Fuchs,
and her post-doc, Catherine Lu,
published a beautiful paper in Science
about how this differentiation occurs
in early human development.
Long story short, what
happens is that there is
an important bone
morphogenetic protein, BMP,
that determines where these hair follicles
and sweat glands are
going to be differentiated
on the surface of the body,
and then at a very critical
time in embryonic development
there is a little tilt
toward BMP in differentiating
toward sweat gland development
as opposed to hair follicles.
So what could've been a terminal
hair like in other primates
becomes a sweat gland instead.
A beautiful piece of evolutionary
developmental biological regulation.
And voila, sweat glands all over.
What do we do with that naked skin?
Well, we sweat a lot, yes.
But it's really important to recognize
that in our repertoire
of behaviors as primates
we engage in lavish amounts
of meaningful touch.
Although we don't engage
in it so much these days
except with our smartphones,
gaining or touching one another
has been an important part
of our communication repertoire
for millions of years,
long before we existed as a human lineage.
But with hairless skin the surface area
for this communication has
become ever much larger.
This surface of communication
is an important portal
for social bonding in
early human development
and continues to be very important
throughout our ontogeny
and throughout our lives.
So even though we legislate against touch
in many workplaces and look down upon it
it is an essential part
of the human communications repertoire.
And we know now that
withholding touch from infants,
withholding affectionate touch
actually stifles infant growth,
not just emotional growth,
but physical growth.
And so infant massage
and affiliative touch are now championed
not only for infants,
but for people throughout the life course.
But the loss of hair had
many other consequences
and although I could go into
this alarmingly long, I won't.
But think about when you lose the ability
to express heightened emotions,
especially fear, and anxiety, and anger,
through piloerection, the
standard mode that a mammal uses
to show its level of
sympathetic excitation,
raising its hackles, raising
its body hair, what do we do?
I mean, we can raise our hairs,
but who's gonna see them?
Well, we have something that compensates.
There's no Botox there.
We have enhanced facial expressions
that help us to
communicate from a distance
what our states of emotion are,
what our emotional intentions are.
And at times that we don't know,
we don't know how distant this was,
but humans with naked skin
began to decorate themselves.
We recognize in the archeological record
we have traces of pieces of ocher
dated from about 70,000
years ago from South Africa.
We have other pieces of pigment
from elsewhere in the world,
very ancient, some 50 to 25,000 years old.
I would guess that these pieces ocher,
at least some of them, were
used to decorate human bodies,
and that even before that
humans who had a sense of self and image
were decorating themselves with clay, mud,
and making meaningful
marks on their bodies.
I can never prove this,
but I would think from the evidence
of all the symbolic behavior that we see
in the lives of early
members of the genus Homo,
early Homo sapiens, even
Homo neanderthalensis,
that over 100,000 years
ago people were decorating
the surfaces of their naked
bodies in significant ways.
Tattooing is universal and people
have been marking themselves.
Otzi, the so-called Iceman
from about 5,000 years ago
had several tattoos on his body
and many modern people,
including many of our students
at Berkeley and elsewhere,
have lavish numbers and
varieties of tattoos.
It has been one of the
most fundamental modes
of communication and self-expression
with the very permanence of it
being its signal feature.
But I'm interested now in
turning to the question
of how we came to have this
beautiful range of colors.
And it's been widely recognized that,
at least since the mid-20th century,
that it's not just sunlight,
but it's ultraviolet
radiation within sunlight
that has been the most important
factor, physical factor,
correlated with skin pigmentation
in the human lineage.
In our work we have been able
to take advantage of databases
that weren't available to
workers in the mid-20th century.
Thanks to NASA's several generations
of Total Ozone Mapping
Spectrometer satellites
we're able to create images
of ultraviolet radiation
at the earth's surface.
This one happens to be annual average UVR,
but we can actually get
wavelength-specific maps now.
This map was created by
my colleague, and husband,
and main collaborator in
our studies, George Chaplin.
And what we're able to see in this
is more or less what you'd predict,
that the highest levels
of ultraviolet radiation
are close to the equator,
but that humid areas,
like the tropics here,
the tropical forests
of Africa, of Amazonia,
of southeast Asia have rather lower levels
than the hot pink and red areas
of the Sahara and the Horn of Africa.
But there are very high
levels in the Andes
and also in the Himalayas.
Very high altitude, even
though not high latitude.
So it was in this environment
in equatorial and eastern Africa
that we think the human lineage
and that Homo and Homo
sapiens are emerging,
an environment of intense
ultraviolet radiation.
Ultraviolet radiation comes
in a variety of forms.
The most biologically significant,
because they come to earth, UVA and UVB,
at the equator in high doses,
especially at the vernal
and autumnal equinoxes.
UVC is mostly screened
out by the atmosphere.
So if we look at a simulation
here at the equator the
UVC is mostly screened out
or absorbed by the
atmospheric oxygen and ozone,
a small but biologically
significant fraction
of UVB penetrates, and a
huge amount of UVA travels
with the visible light down
to the earth's surface.
So the equator is bathed in
a moderate amount of UVB,
in fact fairly high at the
equinoxes, and a lot of UVA.
And these wavelengths have
specific biological activity.
I'm going to come back to this theme
of we evolved under the sun, many times.
So in early genus Homo, mostly naked,
potentially very sweaty skin,
the dark pigmentation
being the essential substitute
for hair, fur protection
against solar, ultraviolet radiation.
Most mammals wherever
they're living are protected
from ultraviolet radiation
by a heavy coat of hair.
If you lose hair you have
to compensate somehow,
and the major compensation
in the human lineage
is the evolution of permanent
dark protective pigmentation.
Eumelanin is the molecule that
I'll be talking about a lot,
sometimes just referring to it as melanin.
This is an amazing
pigment that has been used
over and over again
by hundreds of millions
of different kinds of organisms
that live on the earth's surface
and in shallow parts
of marine environments.
Eumelanin is the superior absorber
of ultraviolet radiation
and visible light.
It's dark, very dark brown to the eye
and it's this beautiful,
incredible multifunction molecule
that's able to absorb UV wavelengths
and as it does so the
large polymer structure
uncoils a little bit, absorbing energy.
It also has the ability chemically
to neutralize so-called free radicals,
a reactive oxygen species,
that are produced in cells
as UV impinges on organisms' surfaces.
So eumelanin has been used
over and over and over again
and this is what we
see that is manipulated
through an easy genetic series of changes
in the Homo lineage in
order to bring about
dark pigmentation to protect the skin
of our active ancestors.
Without going into great detail
about the mechanisms of this
there are many genes that
control pigmentation,
probably over 120 that have some role
in regulating pigmentation in mammals
and some role in humans, but
one of the most important
at this point in our evolution
is one called the
melanocortin 1 receptor locus,
which determines the configuration
of this important protein
which exists on the surface
of the melanin-producing
cells called melanocytes.
Basically in darkly pigmented people,
and here I'm going to
refer to our ancestors,
early members of the genus Homo,
what we see is that this locus
is under strong natural selection
to lose all variation,
so that this switch
effectively switches on the
production of eumelanin,
the photoprotective natural sunscreen,
and reduces the production of pheomelanin,
the yellow-red form of melanin that we see
in red-colored mammals and
primates of various kinds,
and red-haired people, and
freckles on human skin.
Pheomelanin is not photoprotective at all.
Eumelanin is highly photoprotective
and this was the switch that was thrown.
And so we can summarize
by saying in early Homo
we have functionally naked,
or functionally hairless skin
even though the hairs were retained.
We have enhanced barrier functions.
I'm not gonna talk a lot about this,
but we have enhanced
ability to repel water,
to repel microorganisms through a variety
of different compounds
that are actually very good
at fighting viruses, and
bacteria, and parasites.
And we have enhanced
water-protective functions.
So we have this wonderful
series of barrier functions
that also helps to
prevent excess abrasion.
We might not think of our skin
as being very abrasion-resistant,
but it's actually extremely tough.
And it's darkly pigmented.
So early Homo skin is very, very different
from that of our close primate relatives.
When we look at all people
around the world today
all indigenous people and
measure their skin reflectance,
this is data that we collated from reports
collected by anthropologists,
and geographers,
and human biologists over many decades,
we found that skin reflectance
is very highly correlated
with ultraviolet radiation to the extent
that over 86% of total variation
in skin pigmentation in modern humans
can be accounted for by
variation in autumnal levels
of ultraviolet radiation alone.
That's a very large
percentage of variation
that can be explained by one variable.
And so if we look at a
mock-up of human skin here,
we've got the skin layer
here, the epidermis,
there's the dermis underneath,
and the hypodermis.
Here's the atmosphere, ozone, and oxygen.
UVB at the equator is attenuated
by atmospheric oxygen and ozone,
and is able to penetrate
into the epidermis.
It's slowed down a lot
by the dark pigment in the epidermis,
but some manages to get through
and that turns out to be
incredibly biologically important.
A lot of UVA manages to get through,
although the eumelanin in the
bottom of the epidermis here
is quite a good sunscreen and
reduces the amount of UVA.
What happens when UVA impacts naked skin?
It causes all sorts of interesting damage
to DNA in skin cells.
And for the longest time
anthropologists and biologists
mused that this must be the major reason
that protective pigmentation evolved,
to protect against damage to DNA,
which could cause skin cancer.
But in the 1960s a very
good biologist pointed out
that, hold on, people
get skin cancer mostly
after their reproductive
years are completed.
This cannot have a selective effect.
Skin cancer has no evolutionary potency
because it mostly affects
people when they're old.
Very few skin cancers affect people
during reproductive years.
So we must seek another reason
for the presence of melanin.
This is where we came in
and it was in the early
1990s that I realized
that what the connection
between ultraviolet radiation
and reproductive success could be
was actually mediated by a
different set of molecules,
one of which was the B vitamin folate.
The reason that I
identified folate initially
was that folate and its close
biochemical relatives are sensitive
to ultraviolet radiation,
especially to ultraviolet B radiation,
and that folate is also
incredibly important in human development
because it helps to fuel DNA replication,
DNA repair, and DNA
modification or methylation.
In other words folate is a linchpin
in determining whether DNA in cells,
specifically in skin cells,
is going to be healthy.
Folate needs to be protected.
One of the reasons that
this came to my attention
in the early 1990s is
that it was at that time
when people were beginning
to realize the importance
of folate as a determinant
of maternal health
and early embryonic and fetal health
because of the implication
of folate deficiencies in birth defects.
We get our folate from
green leafy vegetables,
and citrus fruits, and whole grains.
We can't store it.
We have to continue to ingest it
and there are lots of environmental agents
that can break down folate,
not just ultraviolet
radiation, but alcohol,
so we need to constantly
replenish our folate intake.
With folate being required for all
of these important functions,
we need to have diets rich in folate.
In the absence of diets rich in folate
problems in early embryogenesis can ensue.
This is what you look
like at 23 to 26 days
of embryonic development.
Your simple plate of cells
is undergoing the process of neurulation,
or neural tube formation.
This process requires prodigious
amounts of DNA production,
cell division, cell migration,
and if it all doesn't happen,
then we can have a neural tube defect
that affects the cranial end,
or the middle part of the spine,
of the lower part of the spine,
and many of these are lethal.
So having made this connection
between a physical force,
a physical influence,
ultraviolet radiation,
a molecule, a vitamin, folate,
and a process, neurulation,
neural tube formation,
and reproductive success,
we felt that we were onto
something that was worth pursuing.
And this really started me
on this quest of studying
the evolution of skin
pigmentation over 25 years ago.
So now when we think about the effects
of ultraviolet radiation
on the human organism
we think about primarily folate metabolism
involved with birth defects.
And now I want to bring
in another chapter.
How folate is necessary in
the regulation of temperature,
of cutaneous, of the sweating
reaction in the skin.
Remember how important naked, sweaty skin
is for a hominin that's
walking and running around,
especially in hot environments.
The skin is the main event for
liberating excess body heat.
And it turns out that folate
is incredibly important
in safeguarding the process by which
this dilation of blood vessels in the skin
thereby provides fluid to
the eccrine sweat glands
that then give sweat to
the surface of the skin.
So here we bring in
another molecular character, nitric oxide.
I'm not going to elaborate long on this,
but it's a fascinating mechanism.
Folate affects nitric oxide in the body.
Nitric oxide is this really
important biochemical messenger,
and in the skin many different signals
turn on nitric oxide, the
production of nitric oxide,
and excite the release of nitric oxide.
It turns out that folate
is incredibly important
in the activation of nitric oxide and then
the vasodilation that
actually occurs in the skin
prior to sweat glands starting to sweat
is triggered by ultraviolet A radiation
penetrating the skin.
So you have folate fueling this process
that is kicked off by
ultraviolet A radiation.
So we have nitric oxide here in the skin
and in the cutaneous blood vessels
just a little bit of vasodilation.
The UVA actually excites the cutaneous
and systemic vasodilation
that is important
in the control of blood pressure.
So we can really begin, or
end, this part of the lecture
about the evolution of dark
protective pigmentation
by saying that really
as far as we can tell
the critical role played
by dark pigmentation
is protection of folate availability
for these important reasons.
And that we have this invariant
melanocortin 1 receptor locus that we find
in most modern African populations
and African diaspora populations.
If we dissect the genome,
and many of my colleagues
have worked diligently
to do this, to look at the
evolution of pigmentation genes,
we can see that there was
a so-called selective sweep
whereby this locus lost
all of its functional variation
under these stringent
conditions of natural selection.
And we'll see that this situation changes
for some populations
later in human evolution.
So during the course of the
evolution of the human lineage
in Africa from early Homo
through early Homo sapiens
here about 200,000 years
ago, to the modern day,
we have the evolution of darkly pigmented,
potentially sweaty skin,
and people can stay healthy,
very, very healthy under intense sun
because the protective
eumelanin still allows
a little bit of ultraviolet radiation
that turns out to be important.
But we have many colors of human skin,
this entire glorious sepia rainbow,
How did it come about?
The story of this is one
of the most fascinating
and important ones of human evolution,
and it has to do, at least in part,
with the importance of
another molecule in the skin.
So here's our darkly pigmented skin
under very strong sunlight at the equator
there's still enough UVB
that penetrates the epidermis
to start the process
of producing vitamin D.
Vitamin D is the second major vitamin
that is in our cast of characters
and turns out to be just as important
to reproductive success as folate.
But UVB
is only available strongly
within the tropics, year in and year out.
What happens when people start
dispersing out of the tropics?
Let's look at what happens
to ultraviolet radiation
in the northern hemisphere
at the winter solstice.
UVC is completely absorbed
again by the atmosphere,
as is UVB.
UVA comes to the earth's
surface with visible light,
so although it's attenuated
by the atmosphere,
by the thick pack of atmosphere,
there's still a lot that makes
it to the earth's surface,
but UVB nothing for a
good part of the year
depending on the latitude.
This has enormous consequences
for human dispersals
and human survival at high latitudes,
whether we're talking about the northern
or the extreme southern hemisphere.
Because ultraviolet radiation
although mostly bad for us
and mostly bad for most organisms
has the one important positive effect
of stimulating the production
of vitamin D in the skin.
From the cholesterol-like
molecule 7DHC, which is present
in the dermis of your
skin, the UVB penetrates,
converts that 7DHC to
pre-vitamin D3 in the skin,
and over the course of a few
chemical steps, conversions,
we have biologically active
vitamin D that's produced.
What happens under
partial UVB, seasonal UVB,
or low levels, and low levels of UVA?
Well, we have some
vitamin D that's formed,
but it takes a much longer time.
These two guys, similar in age,
sunny day in northern California.
The man on the left can
make vitamin D in his skin,
assuming that this is summer
sunlight with plenty of UVB,
he can make vitamin D
in his skin at a rate
five to six times faster
than the man on the right.
Both of them will be able
to produce enough vitamin D
at the end of the day, or
at the end of several hours,
to suit and to meet their
physiological needs,
but the man on the right will
take a longer time to do so.
This was never an issue for people
who were outdoors all the time.
But it is an issue today.
And it was an issue for
darkly pigmented people
who were beginning to disperse
outside of equatorial latitudes
during the Pleistocene.
And we now really want
to turn to the dispersal
of modern humans, Homo sapiens,
beginning around 200,000 years ago.
The best molecular and
paleontological estimates
place the origin of our species
around 200,000 years ago in Africa.
Most of the evolution of Homo
sapiens occurs in Africa.
All of the tremendous linguistic,
cultural, technological,
artistic differentiation of our species,
the tremendous evolution
of our quintessentially human traits
occurs in this early phase
of Homo sapiens evolution
until 70 or 80,000 years ago.
So this tremendously active
Homo sapiens evolution phase
occurring here with dispersals
within Africa occurring.
Beginning around 60 to 70,000 years ago,
and this number changes
in light of new evidence
all the time, but we'll just stick with
about 60 to 70,000 years ago,
we have the first egress of populations
through the Afro-Arabian peninsula,
along the southern coast of south Asia,
and into the hinterland of central Asia.
Down 50 to 60,000 years
ago into southeast Asia,
and then 40 to 50,000
years ago from sort of
a staging post here near the Black Sea
populations dispersing both
westerly and northwesterly
into Europe, and northeasterly
into Asia, northeastern Asia.
Into regions with very low
and highly seasonal levels
of ultraviolet radiation.
This dispersal is sped along
by the incredible cultural
competence of these people.
All of these years of evolution
we had this incredibly
sophisticated and varied toolkit.
We had language.
We were behaviorally
modern in every sense.
And so these dispersals occurred faster
than those of other mammals.
But what happened?
We were going into these areas
that were really very different
from our ancestral solar environment.
And it's important to remember
that probably during individual lifetimes
people didn't travel a lot.
The idea of sort of going somewhere.
Yeah, well, yes, you'd
be looking for food,
and you'd be escaping predators,
but there wouldn't be
active moves very often.
But most people spent time out of doors
and without sewn clothing.
The earliest common occurrences of needles
for the preparation of sewn clothing,
of tailored clothes,
about 20,000 years ago.
Humans were hoofing it big time,
dispersing with mostly naked skin,
and without sewn clothes.
They certainly had the
ability to use animal hides,
and possibly to use plant materials,
but they didn't have the ability
to tailor close-fitting clothing.
So our skin was the primary
interface with the environment.
Throughout the year being outdoors
ultraviolet radiation varied by season
and we adapted to different levels
of temperature and ultraviolet radiation
through biological and
cultural modifications.
Vitamin D is incredibly important in this.
How did we maintain the
ability to make vitamin D
when we were dispersing into latitudes
that had virtually no
UVB throughout the year?
We need vitamin D to build strong bones.
In the absence of vitamin
D to help us absorb
calcium from our diet in early development
infants and children can develop
this bowing of the bones,
nutritional rickets, really, really bad,
especially if it persists into later life.
A young woman who suffers from rickets
throughout her early life will
develop a deformed pelvis,
the outlet of which is compressed,
so that she cannot give birth normally.
Natural selection big time.
We now recognize that in addition
to that classical function of vitamin D
that vitamin D controls
important functions
of the immune system
and of cellular growth and
proliferation in the body.
There are vitamin D receptors
on virtually every organ,
whether we're talking about the brain,
the pancreas, the skeletal
muscle, as well as bone.
So our health turns out to be regulated
in part by this vitamin,
which we never questioned
in our early evolution.
Vitamin D was being produced in our bodies
just because we were alive and outdoors.
But when humans are now
living in high latitudes
being outdoors isn't enough.
And at the highest
latitudes, what we find is
that people can only sustain
year-round habitation
if they have maximally depigmented skin
and if they have cultural adaptations
for ingestion of vitamin D-rich foods.
Their biology and their culture change.
So this dispersal involved
both biological and cultural adaptations
in what we call the vitamin D compromise.
And the first element of this compromise
is skin depigmentation.
I don't talk about so much
light skin as depigmented skin.
Depigmented skin is a derived condition
from our ancestral darkly pigmented skin.
And we predicted this even before
there was any genomic evidence
that these individuals resulting
from two sort of
sub-lineages of modern humans
dispersing into high latitudes
would have evolved independently.
And how beautiful that in the
course of the last 15 years
genomicists looking at pigmentation genes
have found that these groups of people,
northwest Europeans and
northeastern Asians,
have independently
evolved depigmented skin.
One of the genetic loci is similar,
but most of the others aren't.
This is music to the ears of
any evolutionary biologist,
that you would have a
selective force so strong
that it would call upon
whatever genetic variation
was available, and we've got
a big palette, as it were,
of pigmentation genes, that we would use
whatever variation was
available to produce
lightly pigmented or depigmented skin.
And now we know that there are many loci
in many populations that are
associated with depigmentation
under strong positive selection.
And the elucidation of
the different pathways
that have been used in
different populations,
we now know that depigmentation occurred
at least three times and
I would guess it occurred
probably even more than
that in Homo sapiens,
in addition to having occurred most likely
in Neanderthals as well,
our distant cousins.
So what happens?
Under strong selective pressure
low UVB at high latitudes
we have depigmentation,
loss of eumelanin pigmentation,
most eumelanin pigmentation,
so that we have excellent
vitamin D production.
And this is the primary selective force
for the evolution of depigmented skin.
An example of the vitamin
D compromise at work,
and I'm going to take one of many.
This is a very extreme example.
People started moving into Scotland,
modern people, about 10,000 years ago,
and mostly inhabiting coastal settlements.
The people have undergone in situ
maximal loss of eumelanin pigmentation.
Not surprising, even on a sunny day
at the summer solstice
it is not very sunny in northern Scotland.
And there are many days
where there is very, very
little ultraviolet B.
So how did people survive?
Maximally depigmented skin.
But it turns out that even
with no natural sunscreen
they could not make enough
vitamin D in the skin
to satisfy their
physiological requirements.
So year-round habitation required
technology and culture to
harvest vitamin D-rich foods.
People lived near the coast, they ate lots
of cod fish, cod liver, cod liver stews.
People in the hinterland dried fish,
kept fish on the roofs of their cottages
and ate other sources of protein
like blood sausage that had vitamin D.
And they stayed healthy.
So the vitamin D compromise
also involved, sort of,
the tinkering, the genetic tinkering,
of genes that affect vitamin D production
in the skin and its metabolism.
And the introduction
of vitamin D-rich diets
in many populations.
But let's not forget vasodilation.
What happened?
This depigmentation also allows
enhanced penetration of UVA
so that healthy levels of
vasodilation can occur,
reducing blood pressure
and allowing sweat glands
to get the fluid that they need
from the expanded arterials.
So here we have a healthy situation
with a nicely vasodilating little artery
and people are healthy.
In skin pigmentation
thus we can really see
one of the most interesting
evolutionary compromises
that we've been able to describe.
There is operating here
what evolutionary
biologists and geneticists
would call a dual cline.
One that emphasizes photoprotection,
maximal eumelanin
pigmentation at the equator
and in other high-UV environments,
and a cline in the opposite direction
emphasizing depigmented skin
that permits photosynthesis
of vitamin D maximally
under very seasonal
and low-UVB conditions.
A beautiful system honed
by natural selection.
And so the eumelanin
concentration in human skin
is very much related to the intensity
of ultraviolet radiation,
and in middle latitudes we
have people who can tan.
And we are now looking at
the genetic architecture
of tanning, this is some of
my past graduate students,
and we're finding that in all
sorts of different populations
whether they're in the
circum-Mediterranean,
or north Africa, or southeast Asia,
that have tanning ability.
They have different suites of genes
that can be turned on and off,
or on at various seasons,
when there's high amounts
of ultraviolet radiation.
So this is really, really exciting stuff.
The tanning too has evolved independently.
Similar skin colors have
evolved independently many times
under the same UV conditions,
and using different combinations of genes.
So these three darkly
pigmented individuals,
on from Africa, one from
Australia, one from southern India,
have darkly pigmented beautifully,
naturally, sunscreen-rich skin,
and the genetic architecture
of their dark pigmentation
is different in all of these cases.
Very importantly skin pigmentation
genetically is mostly independent
of other physical traits.
So whether we're talking about hair color,
eye color, nose shape, ear
shape, or other physical traits,
skin pigmentation for the
most part is independent.
So these groups of characteristics
that have sometimes been put together
by people for various reasons are not.
They don't sort of walk in lock
step genetically in a group.
They aren't.
They aren't connected.
And they have undergone
independent histories
through our own history.
So we now have this beautiful
sepia rainbow of modern humans
that has evolved in
different parts of the world.
Over time as humans, modern humans,
have dispersed into
different parts of the world
similar pigmentations and
different ones evolving
under similar UV conditions
with different genetic mechanisms.
It is a beautiful story of evolution
of the human body under natural selection.
I tell people, remember Chuck, right?
(audience laughing)
We as teachers, whether we're
teaching in our living room
with our children and grandchildren,
or whether we're teaching
in our classrooms,
we're always seeking
examples of natural selection
and evolution on the human body.
Here is one of the best.
And, you know, I urge people to use this,
because it is understandable,
everybody has skin,
this is something that people can grasp.
Skin pigmentation is a natural compromise
determined by natural selection.
And so we can marvel
at this beautiful evolutionary compromise
and tomorrow we will
consider what this means,
what this beautiful compromise means,
especially when people start moving around
and interacting in ways
that weren't predicted
by our ancestors 20 or 50,000 years ago.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- [Man] So in one of the very last slides
you showed the different
people with different colors.
The person in Alaska had
kind of dark pigment.
Can you explain that one.
- Yes.
I didn't plant you in the audience
but I'm so glad that
you asked that question.
People always ask me about the
dark pigmentation of Inuit.
Inuit and many of the circumpolar peoples
have great tanning ability.
When you look at their unexposed skin
it's sort of moderately pigmented,
but they have tremendous
ability to make melanin
in their skin as a result
of direct solar radiation,
but also from UV that
bounces off the surface
of the water and snow and ice.
So how do they manage?
So here they are, super high latitudes,
Arctic Circle and above,
how do they manage?
They get their vitamin D
entirely through their diet.
And when we look at the
culture of Inuit people
it is built around the harvesting
of vitamin D-rich food.
Whether we're talking
about spearing whales,
or seals, sea lions,
or eating oily fish,
or in the hinterland
chasing caribou or reindeer,
depending on which part
of the Arctic you're in.
You are pursuing vitamin D-rich prey.
And basically people can
maintain good health,
Inuit people, when they are
eating vitamin D-rich foods.
As soon as they start
moving to settlements
and abandon their traditional diet
they have terrific problems
of vitamin D deficiency,
which are now a cause
of great public health
concern and mitigation.
But the fascinating thing
is that natural selection
has worked to enhance
tanning through genes,
complexes that we still don't understand.
Enhanced tanning to protect
against this UVA load
in a sense knowing that the vitamin D
is coming from dietary sources.
- [Man] I'm from the Department
of Nutritional Sciences
and I'm fascinated by what
you said about human foods
and human food cultures and
their role in evolution,
but this makes me think of another element
of human food culture and that is
when you look at a lot
of different cultures
there's something about
hot foods and cold foods
and I wonder if the origin
of the ideas of hot foods
and cold foods may have
actually been something
that helped us to walk out of Africa.
- You mean hot as far
as cooked or hot spicy?
- [Man] Or what people culturally call,
oh, that's a hot food,
or that's a cold food.
And if you ask people from
many different cultures
what their grandmothers taught them
you find a lot of different answers
but so many of them talking
about hot foods and cold foods.
- Yes, and there's a lot
of discussion about this
that some foods are eaten,
especially in the winter
to help protect you against
the temperature fluctuations.
We've never, to my knowledge
no one has actually looked
at the, you know, relative thermogenesis
of these so-called hot
foods and cold foods.
In traditional east Asian
cultures, for instance,
eating turtle, eating
snake in the wintertime
is considered very important
and avoiding those foods in
the summer is equally important
because they're said
to generate more heat.
I would love to know if there was actually
more thermogenesis that was
gained from these so-called
hot or cold foods, but to my knowledge,
no one has looked at this.
- [Man] Thank you for that talk, Doctor.
My question involves our
very hairy ancestors.
(both laughing)
Would it be fair to say that
their primary method or system of cooling
was something other than
evaporative cooling?
- Oh, yes, very good question.
So with our hairy ancestors and relatives
modern monkeys and apes today
actually lose body heat
through their skin,
through their hairy skin,
and they have some sweat glands.
So they are able to sweat a little bit.
There are some monkeys,
the patas monkey of east and west Africa
has a relatively thin coat of hair
and quite a few eccrine sweat glands.
It is the most fast-running
of the non-human primates
and people have looked at the patas monkey
as sort of a model for human sweating.
That there was natural
selection for thinning of hair
and increased density
of eccrine sweat glands.
But the key thing with
all of these primates
is that they did lose heat
through the surfaces of their body.
There isn't a specialized
panting mechanism
or nasal-cooling mechanism
as in other mammals.
- [Woman] A few years ago my husband and I
visited the prehistoric museum in Bordeaux
on our way to Lescar
and there was a mock-up of a small family
of Homo neanderthalensis,
which absolutely fascinated me
because they had light
skin, nearly hairless,
red hair, and they looked like, you know,
a lot of guys I've known. (chuckles)
I know you were careful in
your use of Homo, and so forth,
and I know there were
besides the neanderthalensis
there were, you know, Homo
ergaster, Homo erectus,
I mean, many other Homo species,
but having seen the...
First of all, was it inaccurate?
And then how do you differentiate
the, was it accurate
that they had light skin
and fairly hairless?
I mean the rib cages were more robust,
but in terms of the skin, I'm fascinated.
- Yeah, this is a very good question.
We know that the loss of
body hair in our lineage,
in the Homo lineage, occurred probably
more than a million and a half years ago.
So the ancestor
of the ancestor of the Neanderthals
was a mostly hairless,
sweaty member of the genus Homo.
So whatever kind of species
designation you want to give,
Homo erectus, Homo heidelbergensis,
the predecessor to Neanderthals,
this was a mostly hairless hominin.
We have inferred even
before genetic evidence
that a hominin that would have
been living deep in the past
in a middle latitude, or in, let's say,
about 40 degrees north latitude in Europe,
would have lost most of it's pigmentation.
So we hypothesized this
in one of our papers.
But then just about 10 years ago
using ancient DNA techniques
an excellent Spanish human
geneticist, Carles Lalueza-Fox,
was able to look at the pigmentation gene,
the MC1R locus specifically,
of a very important group
of Neanderthals from Spain.
What he was able to determine,
and this was a very clever piece
of genetics that was undertaken.
He was able to reconstruct the activity
of this particular gene.
So even though it was no Neanderthal there
to sort of inhabit the gene,
if you know what I mean,
he was able to show that the gene product
would have been light skin,
or mostly depigmented skin.
So they actually used the ancient DNA
to reconstruct the action of
the melanin-producing cells
and reconstructed that most individuals
would have been lightly pigmented
and at least, they estimated,
around 10 or 20% would have had red hair.
You know, I think that's a bit
more of a sort of question.
But there's no doubt that the strength
of natural selection was great
when humans were dispersing
into high latitudes.
So it was either be depigmented
or have a lot of vitamin D in the diet.
And I would guess in the
history of various human species
and in various Homo sapiens groups,
we have all sorts of mixing and matching,
that there's strong selection occurring
and some of that is going to be met
through genetic modifications
of readily available genetic
variation when it's there,
and other times it's going
to be met by dietary changes,
and other times it's not
going to be met at all
and the populations become extinct.
- [Woman] I'm going to
ask you a silly question,
if that's all right.
- Go ahead.
- [Woman] So if you have
a black-and-white cat
and you shave it, its skin is
also black-and-white patchy,
so why, I mean, obviously
that's a carnivore,
but why is it that human
skin and pelage coloration
is so uniform on an individual?
- Yeah, it's a great question,
and it's not a silly question at all.
We see throughout primates,
and especially throughout apes,
that we lose our pattern.
So there are some monkeys
that have beautifully patterned coats
and that have similarly
patterned skin under the coats.
But as soon as we get into the ape lineage
we lose, and especially the
large, the African ape lineage,
we lose all of that patterning
for genetic reasons that
we still don't understand.
So when you shave an orangutan,
you shave a gorilla or a chimpanzee,
it's all the same color underneath.
This is a real question as to why,
why we lose this, the relationship
between the hair color and
the underlying skin color.
And this is, as I say,
it is an open question
that primate biologists
who are studying skin
and hair coloration have yet to answer.
But a very good one, not silly at all.
- [Woman] Hi, I have two quick questions
The first one is will you be covering
in the following lectures
what some refer to
as the epidemic of vitamin D deficiencies?
And my second question is
how has skin pigmentation
evolved independently
from other phenotypes if
melanin is responsible
for the color of not only skin
but our eyes and our hair color?
- The first question is easy, yes,
I will be talking at length
about vitamin D deficiency.
What's interesting about
the melanin systems
in, you know, in the hair and eyes
is that they are not under
as strong natural selection.
It's important to have hair on the head.
We know that the hair
on the head, scalp hair,
does serve an important
thermoregulatory function
on the surface of the head,
but the color of the
hair probably hasn't been
under strong natural selection.
But, and we know also that
it seems to be controlled
by many fewer genes
than skin pigmentation.
To make a long and interesting story short
what has happened in the
history of human dispersals
is that there hasn't
been so much selection
of hair color and texture or eye color
but, rather, loss of genetic variation.
So that when you have a
limited palette of genes
and you lose some of that variation
because the dispersing
populations are small
then you're sort of
stuck with all dark eyes.
If you look at eastern Asian populations
all individuals have darkly
pigmented hair and eyes
and I would venture that
that's not a product
of natural selection, it was an accident
of small-population effect
in human dispersals.
Similarly in northwestern Europe
where we know we have strong
population bottlenecks
occurring in the late
Pleistocene and early Holocene
that we have repeated genetic bottlenecks
and loss of variation.
So we might get some really
interesting variations
being thrown up in hair
color and in eye color
but this isn't, it
hasn't been selected for.
Initially it is there because
of a small-population effect,
I would venture, and then later
it may become acted upon by
natural or by social selection.
We do have evidence for
social and sexual selection
of certain of these traits
in certain populations.
But I think it's really
important that we look carefully
at the range of genetic
and population factors
that are occurring and the
sequence in which they acted,
and that we don't just say, oh, yes, yeah,
blondes evolved under sexual selection.
No.
It was a genetic accident
probably then followed
by some social and sexual selection.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Man] Two sort of questions.
One, why is hair regionally
retained on the body?
And a related question, not for myself,
but for those in the
audience who might care,
is there a selective
advantage or disadvantage
to male pattern baldness?
- (laughs) A common question.
Usually put to me by people
with less scalp hair.
In answer to your first question,
this is a really good question.
Answers to why did we retain
these regional accumulations of hair
and in addition to pubic
hair, and axillary hair,
and scalp hair, why do
men have facial hair?
The jury is still out, to be generous,
on most of these things.
I think scalp hair we
can make a strong case
for the fact that it does
locally protect the scalp
from solar radiation and overheating,
and that is allows sort of a,
a space in which the skin
can sweat and lose heat.
So I think that's important.
With pubic and axillary hair,
I think the primary function
is dispersal of pheromones,
because the apocrine glands
that are concentrated there
secrete important molecules
that are used in chemical communication.
We do our level best
to silence them, right,
in modern societies, and
we consider it antisocial
when we can smell somebody,
but smell is part of our
armamentarium of communication
and this has been very important.
We know that it still is
important in sexual attractiveness
even though we do our very
best to eliminate smells.
So I think this is a fascinating
and still ill-studied area.
With beard hair there has been a lot
of interesting recent work
on beards as sexual signals,
as signals of male maturity and male age.
Because the beard changes
color generally more rapidly
than other parts of body hair.
And so not only does the
fullness of the male beard
indicate sort of a fully mature male
but also the change of
color can be a very accurate
chronological indicator of male age,
and that may have been
important in the past.
So these are interesting
hypotheses, all of them,
that have not been tested very well.
There is still a huge amount
of work to be done on hair.
- [Woman] Your very
interesting hairy timeline
at the beginning showed
a rather rapid loss
of hair in the middle.
Is it real, and if so, what
do you think caused it?
- Yes, well, that, the rapid loss of hair
was probably fairly rapid.
For this we really need to
look to the paleontologists
and look at the transition
from sort of an Australopithecine
to a modern Homo skeleton.
That occurred over the course
of probably a half million years.
So, you know, I can't
really say how quickly
the change in skin would've occurred,
but certainly going along with a skeleton
that is fit for walking and running
we know that there
would have been build-up
of excess body heat under
hot environmental conditions,
and if the only physiological mechanisms
available to you are from
the surface of the body
through radiant and evaporative heat loss
there would've been
strong natural selection
for complete loss of functional body hair.
And so I would guess that
transition was quite rapid,
and that little sort of signaling
and evolutionary developmental biology
toward increased differentiation
of eccrine sweat glands,
I think the switch was thrown and probably
the genetic architecture of that change
was under strong positive selection.
- [Woman] I have a very young niece,
who just had kidney transplant.
She's of Scottish heritage.
They've said people who've
had kidney transplants,
of course they're taking
immune suppressants
and the doctors are really dismayed
that oftentimes they'll get
skin cancer within five years.
So I was just wondering,
shouldn't they all be taking vitamin D?
- This is a really good question
and I talk a lot
to nephrologists and
kidney transplant surgeons
all around the world about this
because it is one of the major challenges
to keep people healthy
with respect to vitamin D.
In the case of your relative
with lightly pigmented skin
it is really important that
she stay out of the sun.
So I would say that she needs to talk
to her physicians quickly and efficiently
about what program of
vitamin D supplementation
she should take to stay healthy
because the majority of,
or, I should say many,
if not the majority of
kidney transplant patients
are badly vitamin D deficient.
- [Woman] And what about folate,
or is that a totally different issue?
- Folate is a completely different story
and folate is, you know,
you can get it really, really easily.
There are no easy dietary
sources of vitamin D
unless you really seek out mackerel
and other specific kinds of oily fish.
But folate you can get from
green leafy vegetables,
mostly of any kind, citrus
fruits, whole grains.
You can get folate from
a variety of sources,
so it's easy to top up on folate.
Less easy to top up on vitamin D.
- [Woman] So, then, supplements.
- Yes a supplement but
talk to the physicians
to determine the dosage.
- Okay, well, let's thank
our speaker once again,
and thanks very much for coming.
- Thank you, thanks very much.
(upbeat music)